[Music]
well welcome back to the data science
hangout everyone if you're joining for
the first time it's great to meet you
i'm rachel i'm the host of the data
science hangout
as i mentioned at the meetup yesterday
if you were there i do want to take a
moment to say it's nice to be able to
share some space with everyone right now
what we do at our studio is only made
possible because of the community
and we're all beneficiaries of so many
amazing community members
many of whom are affected by the war in
ukraine right now so we also want to use
this opportunity to support them back in
any way that we can
and so sup and virula who you may know
from the data science hangout had shared
a few ways on linkedin
which we can all help
that i'll share in the chat but if you
do have other information to share
please feel free to do so in the chat as
well
but thank you everyone
and for anybody joining for the first
time
the data science hangout is an open
space for the whole data science
community to connect and chat about data
science leadership
questions you're facing and what's
really going on in the world of data
science
we really want this to be a space where
everybody can participate
and we can hear from everyone
so there's three ways to ask questions
you can always jump in live and maybe
raise your hand on zoom might be the
best way to do that
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and just put a little star next to it if
you want me to read it
or else i can just call on you to bring
into the conversation too
and then lastly we do also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously too
and rob will share that in the chat in
just a moment
just like to reiterate we love to hear
from everyone no matter your level of
experience or area of work too
but for today i'm so happy to be joined
by my co-host stephen bailey steven's a
data engineer at whatnot
and steven i'd love to turn it over you
to introduce yourself and maybe share a
bit about the work that you do
yeah absolutely thanks rachel uh hey
everybody um it's really my pleasure to
be here today um
i can i'll give you a little bit of my
story over the last like five years or
so and kind of where i'm at now um i i
my data journey kind of started uh as a
phd student um doing biomedical image
analysis at vanderbilt university my phd
was on like this cool
mix of
mri images of the brain and cognitive
development and children like
educational pedagogy with with reading
and so essentially what we did was
we brought kids in every summer and took
brain scans of them and then looked at
how their brains changed and
interactions between brain areas changed
as they learned to read and like become
fluent in
in decoding and reading comprehension
it's really fun
got to do like a lot of data engineering
and processing and basically learn
everything from the ground up uh
statistics like the whole data science
you know
workflow
and um towards the end of that program i
decided i wanted to go more into
industry rather than sticking with
academia because i just love the process
so much um i'd never
when it got like by the time a project
got to the poster session and i was like
explaining things i was kind of like
farty tinkering on the next thing so
industry was a great fit i started at a
company called amuda which is a kind of
a data catalog company that's very
focused on compliance related
functionality so for example if you load
data into your data warehouse it has pii
on it a lot of times you want to protect
that data from or or apply permissions
and policies on it so that only certain
people can see it
and so amuda kind of automated that so
got to build out the data team there i
got to learn a lot about data management
a lot about metadata management um and
just recently this year i i
uh went from a director position there
managing a team of about four or five
people
to a individual contributor position at
a company called whatnot which is kind
of like
qvc meets ebay so people can hop on the
app and sell stuff um
you know especially collectibles like
trading cards sports cards
vinyl records vintage clothing
and they can kind of build a following
and um
uh yeah so it's a really interest it's a
very interesting mix of like social
networking
uh real-time auctions
live stream you know live stream data
and i'm running the data platform there
or at least managing sort of the
engineering aspect of it so it's been uh
very much a drinking by the fire hose
experience but it's been really awesome
to start learning
awesome thanks steven i know on these
chats a lot we we talk about what it's
like to move into
leadership or move into like the first
management of data science um role but
what has it been like to go
kind of
the other way back to being an
individual contributor
yeah that's a great question i think um
you know i don't know how like what the
real percentage of you know data
professionals who go into management and
come back into individual contributors
is like i don't know what that looks
like but i i know anecdotally
a lot of people do make that switch
because um
i think for two reasons one is
a lot of us get into data and kind of
like
very organically move into
positions of influence within the
organization simply because we love
answering questions and we love like
getting close to the business problem
and like trying to use data to improve
it and so it kind of naturally i know
with for me at amuta i kind of naturally
moved into a position where um we were
growing we needed more people to focus
on it and i was like situated to lead
that team so it was a very it wasn't
like a
you know i want to go and be a manager
type of experience it was very organic
and so
uh as you as i spent more time in that
role
i learned a ton but i also like missed
the data side because
being like an individual contributor
right now is just so fun i mean you just
get to play with so many cool tools
the the sort of the opportunities and
possibilities of building different data
products is endless it's getting easier
every every month um
and so
that's really what i you know that's
what motivated me to move back into the
data engineering role
is just um
just that opportunity to like build
build bigger cooler more interesting
systems that i hadn't done before
cool
to put us all maybe in like the mindset
of the work that you do it what not i'm
i'm curious what are some of the like
business problems that you're helping
solve
yeah so
that's a great question i think whatnot
is really exciting um because it's a
it's a peer-to-peer marketplace it's
kind of like you know an uber where
you've got a driver and you've got a
passenger and the app is really like
facilitating a transaction between them
so the same is true for us where you've
got a seller with
pokemon cards you've got a buyer who
wants to buy pokemon cards and we have
to put them together um
at the same time like in real time so
that they can have a transaction take
place um so what is really exciting at
whatnot is the focus on real-time
analytics and real-time data um i'm very
much a
a person who's
i come from a world where it's like big
batches big batch processing like with
medical imaging and then even with like
a lot of business data it's not
it doesn't need to be that fast um
because you know as long as the report's
there in the morning like everyone can
kind of do their jobs
but at whatnot because
the because things move so fast the
the ability to implement real-time
systems is actually very important
because if someone's in an auction and
selling something that's valued at five
thousand dollars you know a lot of
people want to go see that and the
auction is going to be over in 30
seconds to 60 seconds because it's
literally like
you know
here's this designer the iphone that
steve jobs uh you know owned and
uh
you know and then it's like starting at
one dollar and it's boom boom boom boom
up to you know five thousand dollars or
whatever so
the speed at which things are moving is
really interesting uh really like
a challenging technical problem to
answer but there's so much opportunity
for building interesting like insights
off of it and systems
that's awesome
i see sep you're uh you just wrote in on
the chat do you want to jump in and ask
that question yeah sure um thanks for uh
taking the time to answer everybody's
questions and and share your story um
you mentioned cool tools that you uh
that you're playing with i wanted to see
if there were some on top of your mind
yeah um
so
you know kind of in the same vein of the
real-time analytics conversation there's
uh there's kind of a whole host of new
databases that are
becoming more popular that allow you to
build
build like streaming
pipelines much easier than you normally
would so i don't
this whole space is fairly new to me but
i think in the past if you wanted to
like stream data from an application and
then consume it by it for a analytics
application
you would have to set up like a kafka a
whole kafka event bus and you have to
have like an analog like a sort of a
streaming uh very like tuned streaming
systems so there's like kafka sql
analytics and other things like that
but now um
tools like rock set and materialize and
time i think time scale db
are are trying to make it much easier to
just write sql on top of these systems
and so as once you set up the pipe
from your event source
whether that's click stream data or
whatever
you can just write sql queries on it and
then expose those to
um to applications and you know
basically you have a very
uh a much lighter weight way to
to make recommend like to implement like
recommendation systems or ranking
systems or
um even like payment process like
payment analysis systems so fraud
detection is like a big question that
we're a big issue that we're trying to
um
focus on and i think data like
the data team has a big opportunity to
help like influence make that easier
so definitely those real-time the
real-time stuff
um
is important is is really cool
the other tool that i just love working
with is um dbt
which is like a data management tool um
and they have some new functionality out
around what's called a metrics layer
which is basically a way to
simplify the creation of like
metrics and kind of govern metrics um
kind of within the database logic
oh thanks stephen
robert i see you just asked a question
in the chat too if you want to jump in
yeah hey there uh thanks for doing this
yeah um i work at i work at our studio
uh
so i was i was curious if you could
clarify what um the difference between a
data engineer and a data scientist in
your eyes because i see that you're
currently a
you your title is data engineer but
previously it was a
data and analytics
yeah
yeah i've i feel like i've kind of been
all over the map from a title
perspective um
i think my training
in
the phd program was very much like you
kind of get trained to be an independent
investigator
and
that that means like you're designing
the experiment you're collecting the
data you're processing the data you're
storing it somewhere for reuse you're
analyzing it you're creating the images
and then you're also like presenting it
so you get this full
life cycle
and
um
i think the same is fairly true of the
business except there's there's this
like
fulcrum in the middle
around the database and so like where
the data is stored and so i would say
the
um the data engineering side of things i
think of more as
designing data models
making like col like ingesting data from
different sources across the company
making sure that those
pipelines are running efficiently and
reliably and really building trust in
the raw data or like the and the
slightly like lightly processed data
whereas the data scientist i think of as
much more
[Music]
like pointed towards a problem area so
the the engineer
i think of as systems a systems thinker
where it's like we're bringing in data
we want to make it reusable for a large
number of applications whereas a data
scientist is very much like
i need to solve a problem i need to
create a you know an applica a specific
application that's going to like or a
specific model that's going to be
deployed to make decisions so
i think of it um a little bit
in those terms so systems thinking and
um and like data ingestion collection
reliability versus
um you know solving a business problem
building something that's generalizable
um you know building a model that's
generalizable for a solution that that
type of
thinking
for uh two just sort of quick follow-ups
to that
are there
is there a lot of overlap in tools for
data engineering versus
science and then
is there a
is there a clear path sort of into
leadership or higher level roles for
data engineering
today
it's a i guess a newish uh
newish field or title
yeah that's a good question um
with my data engine
like with my data engineering hat i
i see a much clearer like relationship
or i feel a much more like closer
kinship with
the infrastructure and devops and
software engine engineering teams um
at not so you know i'm working in i'm
building stuff out in aws i'm setting up
like monitoring and logging and i'm
managing some network
um you know networking type of stuff and
that has a lot of overlap with stuff
that um site reliability engineers and
other infrastructure-minded people
um are focused on and so i do see a like
a career ladder that that looks
similar to a like an engineering career
ladder
i think
and that might
i mean it depends on the i guess it
really depends on the industry from a
data science perspective but i do think
there's
if you have like a data science
organization like there's a clear career
ladder
in that
um
but like at immuta i don't think there
was a very clear career ladder for the
data science people like i think the
data engineering side could could kind
of go up that infrastructure ladder but
then the data science is almost like you
had to go into the business um
to grow
i don't know does that answer your
question
it does yeah thank you
i feel like we're all learning
uh learning as we go with with what the
career trajectory looks like
definitely
meredith i see you have your hand raised
if you want to jump in
thanks uh yeah thank you for your
presentation and answering your
questions i i love how you frame
data engineering versus data science not
so much by the task but by the big
picture of you know the kind of thinking
that
that one does when they're in one
position or another i've heard a number
of people talk about being really
excited about dbt and liking working
with it um can you recommend so i've got
two questions the first one is what do
you recommend
for how to learn dbt
um or get more exposure to it
and then the second one is that so i'm a
career changer and i
am really interested in data analytics
as it relates to
health and so
um to watch your career
trajectory of
starting out working with biomedical
imaging and then shifting out into other
things i'm really curious
for you
um what had meaning for you as it
relates to that work
and did it lose its meaning or like kind
of how your how meaning has been part of
your career trajectory
oh man that's a great question um
okay let me start with the first part
which is about dbt so
what i found um
you know so my background was a
scientist right like experiment and then
i'm taking that experiment to the end to
the conclusion like what did we learn
from this and it's like very project
based
when i moved to immuta i started off and
i was a data scientist and i like had
those projects it's like all right how's
our
product perform under these
circumstances run an experiment present
the results like done
when i started
building out the internal team and the
data platform
it's a very different kind of task
because you're building out an
organization
in organizational capability which is
the data platform so it's not a project
it becomes a system that you're building
and i was not equipped at all
to answer like to understand how to
build a system that's going to be very
reusable
for the company over time because if you
build it wrong that means in a year or
two years you're going to have to go
through and like refactor all this stuff
and so you really want to build it right
at the beginning
what dbt
does
is
the whole the whole shtick is basically
like decoupling
the in the pulling in of data with the
using of data so
dbt basically says all right you've got
data in your database you want to do
like you want to build a dashboard over
here put all of the logic in sql and put
it in your database
and it it basically um allows you to it
makes it very easy to do that and it's
got some like
the way it does it it's like very
heavily nicely managed for you it makes
it very easy for even someone who's very
new to like database management to do it
the right way um right off the bat
and and so it made me much more
um
so first of all it let me build a system
that was not terrible uh right away
and then secondly it helped me to um
and the team improve the system and
build conventions over time and because
it's all in version control it's in
github
um
as we added more people to the team they
could go back and look at like what's
happening they could submit pull
requests and we could have conversations
over new data models that are coming in
and things like that so
um it kind of you get the first win out
of just like
it helps you do things the right way
early on and the second win is it
creates a channel for communication and
collaboration that is
really hard to
to create if you're not using something
like github
so that's why i'm a huge dbt fan
um but your second question about the
like kind of the domain
question and healthcare and and all that
stuff is is also great um
for me
i'm a huge like for me
i get a lot of reward out of
doing things that make like
that i can see an impact on the way
people work or like
like the personal sort of like of
collaborating with people
and
so the types of um
things that i really enjoyed at immuta
were when i could sit down with the
business stakeholder and and like say
like hey like what's your problem and
really understand
like
the sorts of tedious tasks that they're
doing that we could automate
um
i could build like oftentimes it's
pretty easy for a data person to build
something that's going to you know
automatically pull those numbers and
sort them in the right way that's going
to help them help a business user
do actions better and so i found a lot
of value out of that
in my career in industry at whatnot i'm
kind of doing similar things where i can
build pipes and build systems that make
it easier for us to understand our
customers or you know build workflows
that are more efficient
but i do miss i do miss the domain like
the healthcare domain the image
processing stuff thinking about um
the sort of bigger picture of science
and general generalization
i think it's offset a little bit though
because
the data world is so deep and so the
technology is always changing there's a
lot of um
you know conversations around what's the
best way to do this or like what's the
best way to organize the teams and and
all of this stuff so i i find that even
though i miss some of the health care
type of
learning and thinking very deeply about
specific problems there's more than
enough uh exciting stuff for me to learn
and dig into that that keeps me
satisfied
thanks steven
ethan i see you had also asked a
question earlier in the chat too and
love to have you ask that one live
or i can i can read it too and you can
jump in and add more context if you want
but the question was is there anywhere
you see the application of
zero knowledge proofs that help make
working with ppi and ensure compliance
easier
and i'll admit i don't not know what
that means so feel free to jump in with
more contacts too
hi
um sorry yes so zero knowledge proof is
basically a very uh concept um around
cyber security where you can
um validate stuff without actually
knowing
um the actual answers so i was just
wondering if there's any applications
around personal data
that help making working with easier
because you know i'm in europe and
um gdpr is quite a big thing over here
and you know there's a lot of concerns
around privacy
yeah are zero knowledge proofs um
is that like
the same as homomorphic encryption or is
it like a category like a um
concept around homomorphic encryption
yeah it's it's different it's a concept
brow
how do we so basically
um
you can prove to the other persons that
you know something without the other
person
um actually knowing it
so for example if you have a key you can
prove the other person i have this key
but the other person wouldn't know what
the case looks like or
yeah
gotcha gotcha
yeah so
during
i can't speak too
knowledgeably about this specific
question
um i do have some experience with like
implementing privacy
uh
privacy um
enhancing technologies in organizations
so
at immuta we
the the product
would scan a data warehouse for
sensitive data and tag it so like it
would say all right this looks like you
have social security numbers it looks
like you have addresses it looks at
names and things like that and then
there were a couple of um
approaches that we could
automatically implement if you had a
policy
uh that wanted to mitigate privacy
concerns the ones that we had were
masking
technology
masking methods like hashing
redaction replacement with string
rounding et cetera
we had one that was called k
anonymization
um and we had one that was called
differential privacy so i think um
there's a whole other set of
uh methods like zero knowledge proofs
homomorphic encryption
um it's another one i can't i can't
remember but
basically there's there's a number of
technologies that that you can implement
what i'll say is that um
it's
for a lot of organizations
just implementing like the basics
is very very the basics at scale
is very very challenging um because you
have to have a lot of
um
you have to have a lot of metadata
essentially
a lot of high quality metadata to
do privacy
um to do privacy management very very
well so you have to know like
you have to have a language around what
is sensitive data you have to have um
metadata on the data itself that says
like this
column is sensitive
you have to have policies in place in
your organization so you have to know
like actually
you actually have to have someone who's
translating that into
uh an actionable policy of like we need
to mask this type of data for these
types of users you have to have high
quality user data um to know like who is
accessible and in europe you also have
to have like this concept of projects
and purposes uh around like what is
for this person using this data
uh
under these parameters like why are they
using it and you have to manage all of
that in one place um
so it's extremely challenging to get all
those things right i think what what we
found like what we spent a lot of our
time doing at amuda was
was trying to help organizations build a
language um that that would allow them
to address those those sorts of
questions at scale because i think
that's that's really the problem um
so all of that to say i think we
what we found oftentimes was that people
would come in and they'd say like we
want to do differential privacy which is
essentially like randomizing injecting
randomization into your data set
to to provide a level of privacy
guarantees
but then they'd always end up going down
to like let's just mask the data like
let's just mask the data and like get it
like get started using it rather than
like trying to do the the most private
thing first off
i
think individual research teams however
individual teams that have like a very
specific project that they're trying to
do
they can have um a lot more success
with things like differential privacy
homomorphic encryption and that type of
stuff so there's probably a lot of value
for certain
certain use cases that are very well
defined um
you know
so that that's kind of my
i don't know my big picture thought on
that yeah i think that's definitely one
of the masking is definitely one of the
future um data as you know previously
become modern issues because clyde
wouldn't even let us touch the data
because it's too
sensitive and you know in europe you
have to
jump so sort of hoops to be able to work
with personal data
yeah
yeah and it can be hard like
something like that can be very useful
um
you know especially for like
there's there's different phases of of
analytics right so there's like just
knowing that someone else's data could
be useful to you like that's where you
want to have something like like that
zero knowledge proof where it's like hey
can we even start on this question um
because
you might not have
the data that you need um
to actually do anything meaningful with
and and if you can't see it at all you
can't know whether there's there it's
worth pursuing
arafat i see you had clapped and then
raised your hand that sorry i'm guessing
you have something to add to this topic
too
uh yeah hi can you hear me yes
okay hi steven thanks uh
i've been loving this conversation and
everything
the clap was about the conversation but
that was a mistake
but i really appreciate the discussion
uh i actually wanted to ask you about
your transition from being a data
scientist to data engineer
so how is the transition itself and
what would be some of the things that
you think
that really helped you in your current
job
from your data science experience and
what are the weaknesses or things that
you had to learn immediately
the reason that i'm asking because a lot
of times i get recruiters contacting me
for data engineering kind of roles but
i'm currently in data science
area
so i'm trying to understand why and also
why not kind of
yeah i think yeah
so um
i think
so
so for me
i love the systems building part of
[Music]
data engineering so i love being able to
think big picture about like what is the
pattern what are the patterns that we're
implementing in these systems and how do
we make them very high quality and
efficient like implement checks
um and so
and that was true even when i was doing
my phd i often found myself like
gravitating towards the methods and like
re-running pipelines uh and trying to
make pipelines more efficient even when
that probably wasn't the most the best
thing for me to be doing i probably
could have benefited from like doing
more analysis or doing more research so
i've i've always had sort of a system
bent to me
and
i would say
that
the challenge
that becoming more of a data engineering
role like moving more into a data
engineering role has presented is you
have to know
a lot about like the technologies and
you have to learn a lot of um software
engineering patterns that i was never
taught and so
you know things like domain driven
design and um like testing like how do
you design a python package how do you
um implement good testing how do you
implement observability and like log
tracing across multiple systems
networking
um concerns uh that i'm networking still
like i
i learn it and then like i wake up the
next morning and i have forgotten all of
it um but there's a lot of there's a lot
of technology like i would say the
technology side of things is much more
important in
in the data engineering world than it is
on the data science side
i think i've
i think one thing that i bring to a data
engineering role that i wouldn't have if
i hadn't spent time as a data scientist
is
understanding use cases for data
a lot of data engineers will will kind
of
i guess i don't want to put this on a
lot of data engineers but like my
impression is that
if you are coming in just as a data
engineer you could silo yourself kind of
like in the back end and just be like
laying down pipes and moving data from
one place to another and kind of get
stuck in that role
but
a good data engineer i think has a lot
of leverage over helping the
organization like get data not just
to places on the right time but in the
right way with the right metadata that
makes it useful like do some
pre-processing of data to make it really
easy for data scientists to
um to work on it and so i think i bring
a lot of that like context like
contextual information about how data is
going to be used which makes me better
at building the systems for the
the users
i mean if you think you like it it's
i mean i think all of data is a great
place to be right now but data
engineering in particular is a
spectacular place to be because it's
very it's it's evolving constantly
you can have a lot of impact in your
organization and there's just a ton of
stuff to learn um and a very very
interesting exciting stuff to learn
great thanks
i see that kind of touched on your
question as well naveed but just wanted
to see if you have any follow-up there
too
yeah let me just unmute myself and show
my show my face uh so i work at kaiser
permanente and leave the causal
inference function at kp
and so i was just curious i mean as you
know ds is pretty wide i mean you can
get in to a lot of different areas in bs
what part of ds did you end up leaving
to get into data engineering i wonder if
if it was conditional to that as well
yeah um
so my phd was in a lot of the the
engineering
a lot of the
data science work was computer vision
related so you know we would get these
four dimensional brain images where
you've got like the brain you know
three-dimensional brain block but then
it's like it's changing over time and
you'd have to register and normalize all
the stuff and then run stats across
both within the the time series of the
brain and then across subjects and so
it was computer vision plus like
stats like population stats anovas and
stuff like that
when i went to immuta the data science
was it was really more data analytics
than data science because we didn't have
any
any um
sort of cutting-edge use cases for
things it was more like hey we need to
we need to model the business and
have very reliable trustworthy metrics
around
user behavior and sales performance and
all these different things so i kind of
went from
what i would really call data science
and or even just science
to just data analytics now to more of a
dedicated data engineering role
all right
yeah thanks
thank you i see there was an anonymous
question asked earlier on slido
that was if you had to choose would you
prefer being the first data science data
scientist at a company or being part of
an existing group of data scientists and
would the path to becoming a manager be
different
that's a great question um
i think there's pros and cons and you do
have to ask yourself like
i think a lot of self-knowledge comes
into play here
for me
i like
i like i get super excited by learning
new things and and being able to build
things um i am like
you know
98 of my excitement goes into the first
like 80 of the project and then i have
two percent left for the last 20 i'm
like that kind of worker which is not
necessarily
it's not the best kind of worker in a
lot of contacts
um but it's great for startups because
everything you do is new like so if you
want to stand up a database no one is
going to stand up a database for you you
have to learn like go into amazon and
like pick your database and
decide how you how many nodes you want
and like set up the networking and the
security groups and stuff like that so
what's great about being the first data
scientist at a company
is you get to write the you get to build
the system you get to understand um
you get to chart the territory you're
like kind of like you know you're the
pioneer um
charting the uncharted territory
so that's very um that can be very
exciting for people it can also be very
overwhelming um and lonely because
you don't know if your decisions are
going to be right um you don't know if
like you're gonna have to
rebuild the system in the future you
don't you might not even know what
you're doing really
and when you if you start learning like
aws and stuff like you probably
definitely won't know what what you're
doing for a while
um
so
i i loved that when i left
uh bermuda i knew for sure that i wanted
to join an existing data team because i
wanted to learn from others i think
that's the
um
that's that's one of the differences is
uh if you're doing it if you're charting
your own course there are great
communities out there there's great
learning materials out there but you're
still going to be ultimately alone
um
to some extent i mean you'll have
business partners and stuff but i knew i
wanted to join an existing team
um because i wanted to learn from other
people i wanted to see what other people
were doing how they were doing it what
kind of dashboards were they building
what kind of conversations were they
having what like opportunities that they
see and it's been very very rewarding to
be in that sort of position
for this and whatnot so
it's a it's just like anything it's just
got trade-offs i would say
if you want to be the first data hire at
a startup
go for it but just make sure you know
kind of what you're getting into um and
and are prepared for that
thanks steven that's great advice
i am i see sloan you had asked a
question earlier about working with
real-time data do you want to ask that
one live
hi sure
let me also turn my camera on uh so you
mentioned earlier that you went through
when you started at whatnot
working with real-time data in
comparison to batch data in the past and
i'm curious what unique and specific
challenges that you ran into when
navigating that switch
yeah so i mean this is very much an
active area of um
of work for our company
but
it's a
what i would say is that the technical
side of things matters a lot more
with batch data you can kind of
you know just shove stuff into an s3
bucket or like you know not think too
much about schedules or
efficiency of processing and things like
that if you're trying to deliver
real-time analytics to an application
uh like a mobile application
there's almost no room for error like
you have to be thinking because you're
trying to do it whatever your sla is it
might be five seconds right so you think
like
by the after you click a button you know
that event has to go
somewhere and then it has to have logic
applied to it maybe it has to be joined
with other data or a model has to run on
it and then it has to be sent back to
your mobile device
and if anything
takes if it takes 20 seconds like
as a mobile user that's an eternity so
the stakes are just so much higher
because you are trying to
to do something much more um
you know that affects the user much much
more closely and is much more
interactive
um so
that's um
that's one of the biggest shifts i think
just from a sort of emotion like almost
like an emotional standpoint of like
people are going to be using this this
is going to affect the user experience
if this thing doesn't work then like
maybe
a show doesn't show up on someone's feed
and that means that seller doesn't get
featured as much which changes like the
seller's perception of the
um of you know their experience on the
app um so it's it's that sort of um
prominence of the uh of the system that
i think is really interesting
i see ian had asked earlier um what's
your opinion of r as a data engineering
tool versus other languages like python
or c for example
um
i'm not a
i'm not an expert in r i used it during
my um
phd a number of like for a number of uh
use cases i love r shiny i it
r is like so much more elegant for
uh a lot of data science work than
anything in python that's money after
using after i but i made a deliberate
switch to learn python for two reasons
one was because a lot of my work was
using image processing libraries that
required me to
do script like um use things like opencv
or um
what's the pi uh scipy
there were just more libraries out there
for image processing work um
so i focused a lot on python there
as i've um
and i've i've
my
sense is that
there are more out of the box solutions
for python like it's much more of a
lingua franca in the um data engineering
world
than r is
um
just for like thinking about like what
aws provides like [ __ ] provides a um a
cli for python not a cli but a library
for python users to interact with
resources um in aws
maybe there's something like a boto3 for
r i'm not sure
but i would say
that outside of if like to the extent
that you have to do things outside of a
like data management and processing flow
like um
like pull like ingest data move data
from a
source system into a database but not
like doing the processing on the fly
my guess is that python has a little bit
more um
uh
more
libraries out there but i don't know i
guess that
i haven't i never evaluated r directly
for data engineering use cases
so i'd be curious i don't know if anyone
else has thoughts on that um that'd be a
good one if anyone has any
yeah i see a few people sharing comments
in the chat too or libraries that don't
exist or libraries that do exist to help
interact so feel free to jump in
um i uh a few years ago we had like this
i mean to speak about startups and the
wonderful world that they are um
you know sometimes things are like
deadline right and it's like okay we
need this two weeks uh i certainly enjoy
that i think i'm also come from a
science background so i don't mind kind
of
you know going into the unknown and kind
of just iterating and learning as i go i
think it's a wonderful learning
opportunity for those that that are
interested
um but uh but yeah there was a project
that required like a two-week turnaround
and first several days i was looking to
grab data using r
and then interacting with aws
and there was like one package but it
hadn't been updated in like several
years and it just did not work
whatsoever
uh and so i had to basically then
revert into using uh photo three but
using reticulate so
that way i can kind of coalesce the the
analytical stuff that was happening with
kind of extracting and using python
uh win for reticulate um obviously you
could do that in just python and kind of
connect it that way too but um but i
haven't heard of pause so maybe ian
would speak about that
yeah hi everyone um so
uh pause is more of like an sdk than
like a a really easy to use functional
or library but i have had a lot of
success with interacting with uh s3
dynamodb in particular is very easy to
use through that package
and i'm on the github repo right now it
looks like it was updated 12 days ago so
i think there is an active maintainer
that's too long ago again
free to put that link in the chat to me
let me see what other questions we have
here i see yousef you had asked a
question in the chat do you want to jump
in
i can i can read and you can add more
context too if you want to
yes i i just have a question if uh
what what what the most
part of
open source tools for your azure
engineers
yeah so one of the i think one of the
fundamental um
things
that most data engineers are are
responsible for at some point at some
point is like the
ingestion pipelines that you know either
etl or elt is kind of the new um
pattern of just like extract and load so
replicate the data into your warehouse
and then do the transformation in the
warehouse or in the data lake um
so you spend a lot of time like building
setting that up
but there are some good tools out there
now i'd say in the last five years tools
like five tran
stitch
meltano airbite is another one now
that have
essentially made it um
a commodity like data replication a
commodity where
if you are using a standard
customer what do they call them crm
customer relationship management system
um usually there's a connector that's
out there that you can just kind of plug
and play and extract data into your
warehouse and like the 5 train has
hundreds of connectors
and so those sorts of frameworks and
tools make it make the data engineers
job a lot easier from
engineering like from a
movement
perspective but i'd stay i'd say there's
still a considerable amount of time
being spent there
because you can always continue to
optimize it too so one of the things
we're talking about now even outside of
the real time system and whatnot is how
do we get more
um
how do we get data in quicker how do we
do more like get our batch processing
down from a 24-hour batch process down
to a three-hour batch process or a
two-hour thing and so that sort of
optimization of the system is something
where i'm constantly thinking about as
well as data reliability and testing and
making sure like building guarantees
around some of those core data assets
that we have
spent a lot of time thinking about that
the one of the areas that i think is
newer
i think something that is emerging in
the data engineering world is the data
engineer as
as not just a technical person but as a
systems builder and a systems thinker
some larger organizations have data
architects
but this sort of idea that we have like
across the whole company you have
information flowing around and we need
to be able to have a
we want to avoid a situation where as
the company grows you start having all
of these data silos and everyone's like
getting their own sources of truth and
like creating their own metrics and
another metrics agree
the data engineer is really well
positioned to think about like
how does data move throughout the
organization what sort of conventions do
we want to put around
publishing data products what sort of
guarantees do we want to make what kind
of language we want to use what's what
compliance patterns do we need to
implement
to make sure that our data is being used
uh correctly
um
so i think increasingly i'm going to be
thinking about those sorts of
organizational decisions not so not just
the technical but actually like the
human organizational patterns that
around data access and usage
stephen i see tatsu had a question as
well he said as a fellow recovering
academic if you want to jump in tatsu
yeah sure thing
hey steven um great to see another uh
post phd doing well in industry
um
so actually it's pretty funny because my
my background is um very similar to
yours um i i think you said you were
imaging well while you had kids reading
or something like that mine uh is
basically sub uh eeg for the imaging
medium and then uh we had kids
exercising so a lot of a lot of
similarities there um i ended up landing
um in the in the customer success space
i work at our studio
um and of course you know i have a
background in using our studio and and
here i am right um but
um i found interesting so far from you
know here and there as you're answering
questions right is um
i'm i'm very curious on your perspective
on you know that transition and like how
easy or hard it is right for me i i
think it was very difficult um i you
know i come from psychology uh which
traditionally um kind of all they teach
you to do is become an academic right um
there isn't a whole lot of help for you
as the student who's you know
considering a career and you know maybe
a data
related role right which lends really
well to the skill set that you're taught
but there isn't any course that that
teaches you how to do that transition
there isn't a whole lot of networking
events that lends wealth to that um and
at the same time right like i i think
that from
the industry side um i think people are
starting to recognize that oh wow like
people
um that come through the phd pipeline
they have a lot of what we need um but
the issue then becomes right from our
perspective we don't know how to phrase
those those skill sets right to be able
to apply it in a in an interview setting
or anything like that so i just i just
like to hear your your kind of thoughts
on that is it kind of a
failure of the the higher education
system or is it something more that
um you know industry folks could be
doing better to identify
that's a that's such a great question
and i do love like anyone who's not
familiar with the brain like the brain
uh neuroscience community it's like
there's a whole like subfield of
psychology that's just like
what's your brain look like when you're
doing this and when you're doing this
and when you're eating candy and like
when you're looking at uh frogs
it's like there's endless uh endless
opportunities for um for research and
it's really i mean it's amazing
i mean there's a lot of amazing research
um and findings from that but
i you know i totally i totally feel you
and i'm trying i'm i
i think my brain um
is scrambled on it uh a little bit
how do i say like it's such a it's
almost like a relationship when you go
with a phd program
um you do feel like
it's it's it's both it's not it's a job
but it's like more than a job too
there's like it's almost like you have a
relationship with the field and you're
very invested in the research and you're
like it's you're being you're part of
the scientific community and i think one
of the things that's very jarring
about leaving
um
a field is
you lose that it's all you feel like
you're getting divorced or something
like that like you're like you're
severing that relationship
and you're severing that community
because it is it is almost two different
worlds and so
i think
for me i identified pretty early on that
i wanted to
move out and that helped me because i
was able to spend a lot of time
talking with people who weren't in the
university and building relationships so
that when i did transition um when
graduated i already knew like
i knew people who were on the other side
so to speak and so i didn't even though
i felt
lonely and i was the first data science
hire and like no one knew what a data
scientist did and no one like
i also felt like i had a pretty good
understanding of
business of like this is what a business
this is what doing data science and
business doing data in a business looks
like
um so
i think that if if anyone's thinking
about transitioning or doing something
similar
um
i think that's a very like talking to
people and building relationships before
that transition can really help
um make it softer
but
like
you wish you could have some help right
i mean i had a very very similar
experience like where
when when you go through a phd program
they teach you how to learn right we we
know how to learn how to learn and we
can learn how to to you know figure out
this whole this whole getting hired in
an industry role sort of thing and
that's exactly what we do right um but
yeah it would have been nicer right if
you didn't you weren't the one that had
to actively do all all this
this networking um necessarily right it
would have been nicer if there was just
kind of some easier formats for you to
kind of plug yourself in yeah i had i
had an interview um
you know one of the things that kind of
surprised me is i was this biomedical
imaging phd in
vanderbilt in nashville and nashville is
like a huge health care hub and i
couldn't find a job i i like it looked
for
quite a while and i couldn't find a job
and i met skepticism i met i had one
interview where they were kind of like
you sound great
but why would you want to work here
and then i had another job that was like
well we don't really do any imaging
stuff and you know i was kind of like
i'm like i don't
i it's about the learning it's about the
impact it's about like it's not about
the imaging you know it's just one
example this is just one subset of
problems that i'm interested in um and
so you do
um
you do have to go through like and
intentionally think about branding
yourself and think about like um
i think the biggest thing in industry is
you can't get
um
you can't get obsessed with the problem
you can't follow you can't fall in love
with a problem um it's much it makes
your job of finding a job and like
fitting in much harder you have to fall
in love with the
um
your position in some way like like
you're you're the way like
how you're solving problems uh more of
like
applying the mindset of a scientist into
this business context i think
whereas on the other side like
in in academia you just fall in love
with a problem and you kind of like
figure out the methods you know
that makes sense and how to get money
and all that stuff so
it is
i i'd say that's the biggest thing you
know it kind of goes back to that domain
question um
that we talked about earlier where it's
like
if you love healthcare um
yeah if you fall in love with a
particular problem in healthcare it's
harder to pursue that problem across
companies because there's there's much
fewer problems fewer companies who are
looking to hire for that one problem
yeah sounds like this question hits home
for a bunch of people in the chat too so
maybe there's people who are willing to
talk to others
who are going through the same thing
but i see steph you were also sharing a
few tips in the the chat too if you'd
want to
say those too
yeah i mean
i haven't spoken to a phd where you know
things like this stuff don't resonate
right and um i've certainly struggled
through that myself it does you everyone
carves their own path i think as tatsu
was saying you just kind of you learn to
learn you kind of figure it out i think
that the skill sets that everyone's
learning in graduate school no matter
what the subject area is
are very helpful in being able to
address that but uh you know my biggest
thing my biggest advice would be don't
be afraid to reach out to people most
people are very willing to to talk to
you about what their journey was no
matter where they're at in in their
career whether they have a phd whether
they don't have a phd and once you kind
of see that you start to talk to people
you realize that
your uh your um
room is much bigger right there's
there's a lot of people
from all walks of life that have moved
multiple careers or multiple industries
and so um
you know finding that through whether
that's your local community whether it's
the data science hangout whether it's
something else i think that's the number
one thing and then and then you feel
like uh
you know you find the right people
it is pretty amazing the networking that
can be done virtually
just on linkedin as well like sometimes
i forget like oh i i met these people on
linkedin first like in my head i feel
like i know them so well like we had met
in person at some point um
meredith i see you also had a question
in the chat would you want to jump in
without one
sure i know we're almost out of time but
i was just thinking about what the
limitations are between higher education
and industry collaborating more you know
i've seen some really great
collaborations especially it seems like
certain departments within any
university
do a really nice job connecting with
industry in the community
but if i don't know if it's discipline
specific or i'm curious if you hear what
people's thoughts are about the
limitations of collaboration
i think my experience at vanderbilt i
saw a lot more industry collaborations
on the engineering disciplines than i
did in like psychology for example or
education i saw quite a few
collaborations with like uh public
institutions so you know whether
i know at vanderbilt they had like these
um big big surveys and big studies that
the the university would do in
partnership with the state department of
education um policy and analysis and
that type of stuff
um
and then in the biomedical engineering
program it seemed like there were a lot
of grants you know a lot of a lot of
work
was stemmed by grants that they would
get from industry
partners and in fact like i think google
invested a bunch of money into
one of the labs we worked with at
vanderbilt so
it's a great question though i think i
think more
more is better for sure just just from a
training and opportunity perspective
even i know we're a little bit over
there's i think two more questions if
that's okay or do you have to run nope
that's fine okay awesome this is awesome
by the way this is like the best
this is the best zoom
thing
i've been a part of in probably the last
year this is awesome like this
thank you
thank you all for making it what it is
um ethan i i see you had another
question a bit earlier in the chat and i
can't find it so i'm gonna
pull you up please and ask that
are you making all right sorry uh
yeah i just want to ask because um
you've worked with
both data engineers and data scientists
um
what are the things that
what is your first what is your point of
view of data scientists and what do you
think
they should do more and what do you
think they should do less because we
oftentimes hear these um
conversations between data engineer and
data scientist
um that you know
they're the perception of both roles and
um what is your peer point of view in
that
yeah so
um i would say for data practitioners in
general and this goes for analysts and
scientists um when i was managing the
team at amuda one thing i found myself
saying to
our data scientists a lot was like how
can we simplify like simplify simplify
like
things
because in the business context and
again we're a smaller company we weren't
building like you know we weren't
building like models right that had to
like accommodate a bunch of stuff
we were building more of just data
products and dashboards and scores and
things like that for for our business
consumers but
having the you can't i can't overstate
the value of having transparent
logic
for
end users and we talk a lot about like
you hear about explainability um in the
context of like neural networks but the
same is true for
anything like any function that like
takes input data and then like outputs
something
uh the more explainable that is the more
likely it's going to be adopted
um
and by the business user and so like if
you can
get the same if you can get the same
output from logarithmic regression that
you can from like some bayesian model
like go with logarithmic regression so
it's kind of cliche i think at this
point but
i've seen it in practice and it has a
big effect
the other thing i would say is
just always thinking
with an eye to deployment like
you know can we do this
what's the simplest way we can do this
and so that we can
get it in production as quickly as
possible so can we do this as a sql
statement like that was a lot of times
the decision that we had to make on the
muta team like can this be a sql
statement
that produces a table that can be read
in or does it need to be some python
like
lambda function that runs on a schedule
because
that additional complexity
is
it compounds as the system grows so
the more you can kind of keep things
simple
um the best the better
yeah
reminds me of me about like data science
and then being unmasked is actually just
it fails underneath
exactly yep
and i would say always do the if else if
you can
you can still call yourself data
scientist i mean they do it in science
too right like you never want to look at
actual like professor's code um
because just read the paper um
get the get the insights don't worry
about what's underneath yeah but to be
fair the xj boost is also just fancy he
fails
yeah
that's true
olivia i see you also had a comment
around building trust and data or
lightly processed data
do you want to jump in and
and add any context to that
um sure so that that's kind of part of
my job right now i'm doing like data
engineering by proxy working on data
integration and
it's very very complicated but that's
part of my challenge is
making sure that we can build trust in
our data and our lightly processed data
and our consumable data
um
and you know
doing that is all new to me change data
capture and business rule
externalization can you talk anything
about that
yeah so one of the light bulb moments
for me
um
was
at leading the data team at immuta and
like starting to grow the system was
reading a book called
data management at scale it's very like
theoretical um but
one of the principles is this idea of
domain driven design
which is
as data comes in
to your system
you don't want to build just like a big
black box where it's like again it's a
kind of explainability right so when
data comes in from
you know the marketing team and the
sales team and the
customer success team you don't want to
just like merge it into one like super
super
super table and then like expose it you
want to try and set up like
interfaces where it's like all right
here's the lightly processed marketing
data here's the lightly processed sales
data here's the lightly processed
customer success data and kind of keep
some um
keep some
you want to track the lineage right so
that you know like hey this is coming
from here and then if someone from
marketing or sales or product comes in
they don't have to ask like where does
this come from like where's this
marketing you know i'm looking at sales
data but i'm getting all this extra
marketing data with it what i found is
that
um
the more you can do that the more people
can
like uh feel feel ownership over it i we
did this one thing
at muta where we exposed salesforce
which is our customer relationship
management platform it has like all of
our customer lists and stuff in it
um salesforce data comes into the
warehouse then it gets exposed in our bi
tool looker
and
there was this weird thing where the
person who
managed salesforce would look at numbers
and looker and they would be like i
don't know what these are
like they wouldn't they didn't feel
ownership over it simply because it was
like going through our pipes
and so we re-architected things and
tried to keep it much more like
domain oriented and they
that had the
positive effect of like making them feel
more ownership over it because they
would go and they look at looker and
they look at salesforce and be like okay
this matches up like and they they kind
of go and do that
and that sort of building trust and
building familiarity with the data is is
is really hard
but i think it's it's easier
if you can keep things separate and
lightly processed um and and just have
good documentation and clarity but it's
it's a challenge i think it's probably
one of the biggest challenges in data
management
thank you so much
thank you so much steven for
jumping on and sharing your experience
with us and and thank you all for asking
all these amazing questions too
i just wanted to see stephen what's the
best way to get in touch with you if
people have follow-up questions or want
to connect
is it linkedin
uh yeah linkedin is good i have a
twitter account i try um twitter kind of
scares me and i don't want to get sucked
in um so i i don't post on that too much
but
linkedin linkedin is good i started
writing more this year and so feel free
to
just subscribe to that um
but uh yeah i really appreciate all the
the time everybody this is awesome
thank you so much and if people want to
continue any of the conversations from
today i'll put the linkedin group in the
chat too
and feel free to start your own
discussions there i usually share a few
of the helpful links there too
thanks all have a great rest of the day
you